عمر الحاج متواجد في ازمير معروف عن ازمير
بانها معقل المعارضه معقل حزب الشعب
الجمهوري الذي يدعو الى عوده اللاجئين
لسيما اللاجئين السوريين الى سوريا كيف
يقارب الحزب عمر الحاج هذا الملف وايضا
الاحزاب الاخرى كيف تنظر اليه
نعم جلال كما هي كل الملفات وكل المشاكل
هناك تناقض كبير بين رؤيه والمقاربه التي
يقدمها كل جانب على حساب مقاربته الجانب
الاخر في هذا الموضوع بالتحديد كان الرئيس
اردوغان قد سئل قبل يوم واحد عند اجتماعه
مع الشباب عن موضوع اللاجئين وحتى كان
السؤال بلهجه الابتعاد ربما او حتى
الانزعاج من الفتره الطويله التي قضاها
اللاجئون هنا خاصه
اللاجئون السوريون كان اجابه الرئيس
اردونيه
المقاربه التي اتبعت تبعها حزب العداله
والتنميه والذي قال ببساطه ان الحرب هناك
لم تنتهي وان هناك
خطرا على حياه هؤلاء ولكنه اشار الى ان
الحكومه تسعى الى تطبيق عوده طواعيه الى
طوعيه لهؤلاء اللاجئين ولكن وانها تهيئ
تحاول ان تهيئ لهم الظروف واسباب البقاء
واشار الى المشروعات التي قامت بها
الحكومه وايضا مع المنظمات الدوليه لانشاء
مدن صغيره والاستعاره عن الخيم عنها بيئه
عن الخيم عنها في تلك المناطق ولكن
المقاربه لكن المقاربه الاخرى التي تقدمها
احزاب المعارضه وان كانت متباينه في طريقه
الطرح التي
توصف في بعض الاحيان بانها طريقه اقرب
للعنصريه ولنشر خطاب الكراهيه على الاقل
حزب الشعب الجمهوري هو الاخر يعد بترحين
هؤلاء اللاجئين خلال عامين فقط وانه تقول
وعوده الانتخابيه ان حزب العداله والتنميه
من وجهه نظره في هذا الملف وانه فتح الباب
على مصراعيه وترك الحمله على الغارب لكل
من اراد ان ياخذ من تركيا مكانا للجوء